i'm brandes daniel and i am backstage at
the drew barrymore show i just wanted to
talk about a few things that our viewers
at home can really think about when
they're thinking about their look
there is not a one size fit all for
anyone think about your attributes what
do you love the most so for example for
me i love my legs and guess what i'm
always trying to show them what i dress
so think about like what's your best
feature and really accentuate that
[Music]
a white shirt
is probably the best piece you can have
in your closet because there are so many
different things you can do with that
you can give it a pop of color at the
bottom you can actually not button up
the whole white shirt but tie it at your
waist you can wear it kind of open and
low at the top with like some beautiful
chunky jewelry so don't be afraid to
really make a white shirt your own
[Music]
and everyone needs his closet staple it
is a scarf because you can dress up
things you can dress down things with
the scarf it also can change the total
look if you have one dress that you love
to wear all the time if you put
different types of scarves and different
prints with it it makes it look like a
totally different outfit so that you get
more wears out of that
drew this has been so much fun
i'm excited
[Music]
you